just like the mandalorian's inaugural
season chapters 9 through 16 are
peppered with dialogue cold from deep
dives into star wars lore here are just
some of the lines that mean more than
you realized but a quick word of warning
before we begin
a galaxy of spoilers are ahead when cobb
vamp meets mando in chapter 9
he's clearly hoping things won't get
violent in fact he almost instantly
orders quote
two snorts of spochka for them the
weakway bartender then hands over a
bottle of blue liquid and a couple of
cups
while cobb takes a drink mando never
gets to partake in the beverage but it's
still an interesting allusion to the
show's premier season
season one's chapter four is the first
time that spotska is mentioned in the
star wars universe
it's a blue drink made from tiny aquatic
creatures called krill
the krill represent the livelihood of
the same village mando and cara dune
help protect from nearby raiders
the callback is likely intentional
considering mando finds himself in a
similar situation in chapter 9 by
helping a small community to organize
and eliminate a big threat
chapter 9 ends with one of the most
long-awaited reveals in star wars
history the return of boba fett
and consequently the confirmation he
survived his drop into the great pit of
carcoon in return of the jedi
in a commentary track for the film
george lucas said that he had considered
adding a scene to show the bounty hunter
had survived
also in star wars books no longer
considered canon it's explained that
boba escaped and is still alive
while in the mandalorian boba doesn't
reveal how he survived the sarlacc it's
possible an exchange between mando and
cobb in chapter 9 could give us a hint
when mando cobb and the tuscan raiders
first arrive at the crate dragon's lair
mando tells cobb the beast lives in an
abandoned sarlacc pit
cobb responds that he's lived on
tatooine his whole life and there's no
such thing as an abandoned sarlacc pit
mando quickly retorts that there is if
you eat the sarlacc
it seems unlikely the great pit of
carcoon is the abandoned pit we see in
chapter 9.
the terrain is a lot different from the
scene featuring the beast in return of
the jedi
still the revelation that there is a
creature on tatooine capable of eating
sarlax gives us one possible explanation
for boba's survival
in the beginning of chapter nine's final
battle with the crate dragon mando
utters something that sounds like a
curse
as the beast begins to back up into his
lair mando says dank barrack it's going
back in
it's an expression that's repeated
throughout the rest of season 2 by mando
and other characters
while we don't know exactly what the
curse means it's a callback to the very
beginning of the mandalorian's first
episode
when we initially hear the phrase it's
spoken by mando's first bounty in the
series the blue skinned mithril mando
captures in a bar shortly after he and
his prisoner arrive at the razor crest
the fairy that brought them across the
ice is devoured by a monstrous rabbinic
and looks like mando's ship is its next
target as the pair quickly board the
craft the mithral yells out
dank barrick that was close it's
interesting that mando is now repeating
lines from a former bounty though he
doesn't quite find himself in the same
situation as the mithril
it always seems like mando can't take a
single step forward on his journey
without doing yet another job for
someone else first and chapter 10
is no different after his adventures in
and around most pell go mando returns to
mos
eisley to find another lead on
mandalorians and a task he has to
perform for the intel
the mechanic pelimoto introduces mando
to someone known only as the frog lady
who knows where a group of the elusive
warriors live
but she wants a trip back home in return
for the information as she's giving
mando the lowdown on what she knows
pelly translates for him she said her
husband has settled on the estuary moon
of trask in the system of the gas giant
collide
the names of both the moon and the gas
giant are references to heroes from the
star wars legends narrative the moon
trask is named for trask olgo
a character from the 2003 role-playing
video game star wars knights of the old
republic
trask is an officer in the galactic
republic as well as a native of the
doomed planet alderaan
cole ibn on the other hand is named for
a character from the world of comics
cole skywalker he's a jedi descendant to
both anakin and luke who appears in the
dark horse comic star wars legacy
chapter 12 sees the return of a number
of characters including horatio sans
reprising his role as the mithril
mando's first target in chapter one we
also learned that it was grief karga who
put up the bounty on the amphibious
alien
after grief tells mando that the myth
roll is now working for him to pay off
his debt the bounty hunter responds that
he should let him know if the alien
tries to run away again
the myth roll has a quick comeback to
this suggestion let me assure you
i do not want to spend any more time in
carbonite
still can't see out of my left eye this
is a callback to the finale
of the original star wars trilogy return
of the jedi after being freed from
carbonite in jabba's palace the panic
han solo says he can't see
and leia explains that blindness is a
temporary side effect from being frozen
in carbonite
we don't know exactly how long it's been
since the myth world was freed from
carbonite but it seems strange he would
still suffer symptoms from the freezing
it could be he's fishing for sympathy or
it could also be a ploy to put grief off
his guard in hopes of a future escape
after all the myth role isn't known for
his honesty even if he is telling the
truth there's a good chance neither
grief cara nor mando believe him about
his bad eye
since they let him drive the speeder on
their way to the imperial outpost
as mando and his companions are on their
way out of the navarro imperial outpost
they come across a lab filled with
deformed bodies floating in tanks
in spite of their tight schedule the
heroes pause to access records to find
out what the lab is actually all about
mithril plays a hollow recording of dr
pershing the imperial doctor who works
on the child in the first season
among other things pershing reports
quote there were promising effects for
an entire fortnight
but then sadly the body rejected the
blood i highly doubt we'll find a donor
with a higher m count though
by higher em count dr pershing is
referring to one of the most
controversial pieces of the star wars
mythos midichlorians
in the phantom menace we learn that
every jedi's blood includes higher than
average amounts of midichlorians
and that is through communication with
these microscopic life forms that jedi
find their special connection to the
force
the fact that this concept still remains
so polarizing among some fans may be why
pershing says
m count rather than minichlorian count
allowing viewers on the thumbs down side
of the debate to imagine
m stands for something else at the same
time the presence of the lab and
pershing's recording have fed widespread
speculation that the experiments have
something to do with the cloning of
palpatine
and the creation of supreme leader snoke
chapter 13 of the mandalorian sees the
long-anticipated live-action premiere of
ahsoka tano played by rosario dawson
the former jedi teams up with mando
against the forces of magistrate morgan
ellsberg after some close calls ahsoka
defeats the magistrate in a duel
once she has else bit at her mercy
ahsoka demands to know one thing
now tell me where is your master
where is grand admiral thrawn thrawn is
a villain too good to be left on the
cutting room floor of star wars canon
the blue skin imperial first appeared in
timothy zahn's thrawn novel trilogy
starting with 1991's heir to the empire
and concluding with 1993's the last
command
while these novels have officially
joined the list of star wars media no
longer considered canon thrawn was also
featured in star wars rebels
ahsoka's lines let us know that thrawn
is still alive and it's extremely
important that she finds him
it could very well be that ahsoka's hunt
for the admiral will be the focus of the
upcoming disney plus ahsoka tano series
chapter 15 is another great example of
just how far mando is willing to go to
rescue grogu
with the aid of the newly appointed new
republic marshal kara dune
mando recruits former foe makes mayfield
to help him infiltrate an imperial
facility in order to access a computer
that can give him the location of mop
gideon
once they're inside mayfield refuses to
approach the computer console after
spotting a former commanding officer
mandel decides to do it himself and
makes a surprising choice to remove a
stormtrooper helmet he's wearing as a
disguise and expose his face
when mayfield's old commander starts
questioning mando he swoops in to save
the day
successfully bluffing the officer into
believing they're the genuine article
he also tries to make a quick work
excuse so they can get away from him
come on let's go fill out those tps
reports so we can go recharge the power
coil
mentioning tps reports is no doubt a
reference to the 1999 cult classic
office space in the comedy ron
livingston plays peter
a passionless office worker at a
software company who is being hounded by
supervisor bill lundberg about his tps
reports
um yeah you see we're putting the cover
sheets on
all tps reports now before they go out
though decades old now office base is
often still referenced and quoted by a
wide variety of fans
even in a galaxy far far away in chapter
15 mayfield reveals himself to be a much
more layered character than he
originally appears to be in the first
season
he and mando are corralled into sharing
drinks with the imperial officer valen
hess
the same officer mayfield avoids earlier
we soon learn hess holds an important
place in mayfield's history
one with such weight in fact that
mayfield allows it to overtake his
emotions and blow his cover
as hass asked for ideas for toast
mayfield suggests how about a toast
operation
cinder initially hess seems impressed by
mayfield turning to mando and saying now
there's a man who knows his history
we soon learned mayfield served under
hess during the operation and was
traumatized by what occurred
when you find out about operation cinder
his reaction is completely
understandable
it wasn't something dreamed up
specifically for the mandalorian but
instead has been mentioned in numerous
star wars video games comics and other
media
cinder is palpatine's contingency plan
in the case of his death to make sure
the galaxy's civilizations don't outlive
him
weeks after the battle of endor the
empire sets operation cinder in motion
using satellite arrays to cause
disastrous climate changes on different
planets including the boom
no official number has ever been given
for the amount of deaths but it was
clearly significant enough to make
mayfield shoot hess for his involvement
early in chapter 16 manda returns to
trask with allies
hoping to enlist the help of the
mandalorians he found there bogatan and
koska are not happy to see mando
accompanied by boba
whose voice they recognize is those of
the clones created on kamino
koska and boba exchange a few barbs
eventually leading to a brief
altercation
before things get violent bobo warns the
younger koska to calm down
she responds by saying you'll be talking
through the window of a back to tank
back to tanks aren't a particularly
obscure part of star wars lore though
you don't often hear them referred to by
name
there are cylindrical tanks filled with
bacta fluid which is known for its
healing properties
probably the most prominent use of a
bacta tank comes early in empire strikes
back when luke skywalker submerged in
one of the tanks after being rescued on
the planet hop by han solo
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the mandalorian are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you